Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres on parle souvent dans le
débat public d'immigration de manière
abstraite on parle d'économie on parle
de droit on parle de statistiques mais
là on voudrait ce soir en parler de
manière concrète et le faire avec deux
chercheuses en sciences sociales l'une
en histoire l'autre en sociologie qui
ont fait l'une et l'autre une infidélité
alors discipline pour écrire le récit de
la venue en France et de la vie en
France de leur famille respective alors
bien sûr bien des choses les distinctes
parce que la famille de lune est arrivée
dans les années 20 en France depuis la
Pologne et a traversé les heures
tragiques de l'occupation la famille de
l'autre est venue dans les années 70 du
Maroc et a vécu l'aventure de ce qu'on a
appelé les ouvriers immigrés à l'époque
mais tout de même il y a beaucoup de
miroittements entre leurs expériences et
c'est de cela dont nous allons parler
dans cette émission que nous avons
intitulé récit d'immigration
Marianne Tigani mine bonsoir
Mariam vous êtes sociologue vous avez
été clairement engagé dans un combat
antiraciste féministe vous avez fait
beaucoup parler de vous avec un livre
dévoilons-nous dans lequel vous cherchez
une ligne de crête entre disons une
laïcité trop ultra et discriminante et
une trop grande soumission au patriarcat
religieux mais là vous vous publiez un
livre qui n'a rien à voir avec tout ça
notre histoire de France dans lequel
vous racontez la vie l'arrivée en France
et la vie de votre père jeune homme
marocain dans les années 70 et vous
évoquez aussi la vie de votre frère
c'est-à-dire le début de la deuxième
génération d'immigration qui a lui-même
était ouvrier on va revenir à vous votre
seconde invité c'est Annette vieux cas
Annette bonsoir bonsoir année de vous
êtes une historienne très reconnue de la
Shoah même si vous avez fait des
incursions un peu en dehors de votre
terrain sur le la résistance juive
communiste sur les sur les Torres sur
l'avortement mais vous avez commencé il
y a un an des récits personnels plus
personnels d'abord vous avez raconté
votre expérience de jeunes maoïs ayant
été enseignés dans la Chine maoïs de la
du début des années 70
livre très très beau d'ailleurs et là
vous publiez vous avez publié un tombeau
tombeau au pluriel dont vous dites qu'il
est une autobiographie de votre famille
et vous raconter d'ailleurs dans ce
livre que c'est en allant vider
l'appartement de votre tente verte qui
était morte sans enfant et sans avoir
raconté sans avoir écrit ses souvenirs
donc avec la perspective que tout d'elle
allait disparaître vous raconter que
c'est ça qui a finalement été le
déclencheur de votre envie d'écrire ce
livre
oui enfin il y a eu plusieurs
déclencheurs ça ça a été vraiment le
déclencheur mais quand je suis rentré de
Chine après ces années chinoises j'avais
entrepris d'écrire la biographie de Wolf
Viviane
mon grand-père paternel
journaliste est mort à Auschwitz et
j'avais rassemblé toute une
documentation et je n'ai pas été en
capacité de mener à bien ce projet donc
j'ai laissé tomber le projet mais j'ai
gardé la doc et
très précieuse parce qu'il y avait de
très longues interviews notamment de mon
père qui est décédé en 91 donc si je
n'avais pas rassemblé à ce moment-là
cette documentation je n'aurais pas
écrit mes tombeaux mais d'un côté Berthe
Perelman de ma famille maternelle de
l'autre côté wolfeviève yorka et j'ai eu
l'idée de raconter ces deux branches de
ma famille
identiques dans l'immigration
exacte sociologiquement elles auraient
dû être totalement
identiques et on s'aperçoit en fait que
ce sont deux des amis très très
issu de deux familles donc la famille de
votre père vieux vurca dont le
grand-père Wolf et la figure venait de
le dire la figure tutélaire personnage
de journaliste d'écrivains personnages
bohème et de l'autre côté la famille
maternelle les perles man alors ils ont
en commun de venir de ce monde des Juifs
de Pologne parlant lui dit de culture
yiddish mais les uns sont des
intellectuels bohème et les autres sont
des petits artisans
je dirais plus donc très très précaire
et parce que la bohème n'est pas le
choix c'est une c'est une une précarité
qu'on à peine aujourd'hui à imaginer
mais c'est vrai la branche tailleur mon
grand-père à ce qu'elle perel man c'est
quasiment l'idéal type du juif immigré
mais avec un désir très fort de
promotion sociale
et de du côté de
de pays paternel c'est un peu une
famille
un peu balagane un peu désordonné
mais vous dites des précaires d'ailleurs
ça m'a frappé parce que avant la guerre
dans les années 30
quoi qu'il soit dans une situation très
précaire économiquement et même
juridiquement on sent une espèce de joie
de vivre notamment dans le restaurant
que que tiennent votre que tient votre
famille paternelle rudule qui est un
lieu de rassemblement de peintres
d'écrivains de juin on sent malgré la
précarité de la situation une
fantastique joie de vivre ces vif qui
viennent d'une tradition qui étouffe
sous le poids d'une de la de
l'orthodoxie juive il y a le désir
d'aller vers la création et il y a des
dizaines et des dizaines
d'écrivains ils disent et on a vu au
musée d'Aristote du judaïsme
l'exposition sur les peintres de l'École
de Paris dont des dizaines sont morts
pendant le pendant la Shoah mais il y
avait cette espèce de créativité cet
amour de l'art de la littérature et ces
milieux qui étaient aussi des milieux
très solidaires mais ce qui est frappant
aussi c'est que il conserve leur culture
ils sont en France ils essaient de
s'intégrer mais la première génération
en tous les cas reste au sein de
l'ensemble français dans un univers qui
est très fermé sur lui-même très hiddige
très
enraciné dans sa culture initiale mais
je pense que il y a pas le choix c'est à
dire que le yiddish c'est pas le choix
chez mes grands-parents ça devient un
choix chez volvivorca parce qu'il en
fait
l'ossature de son idéologie qui est que
il y a une culture juive qui est la
culture yiddish et qu'on doit pouvoir
développer dans le pays dans lequel on
vit cette culture donc chez lui il y a
une pensée du yiddish mais du côté de
mes grands-parents maternels ils sont
tout simplement des immigrés parlent pas
la langue c'est les enfants qui font le
qui font l'intermédiaire avec le monde
extérieur qui parle cette langue avec
leurs parents mais qui déjà ne
l'écrivent plus ne la lise plus et
il ne la parlerons plus une fois que
qu'il y aura plus ce milieu donc c'est
un autre soir qui n'est pas de l'ordre
du choix mais qui est
j'aurais pas faire de la sociologie mais
une pesanteur sociologique
alors il y a évidemment les événements
tragiques de la guerre parce que vos
grands-parents paternels vont
disparaître dans la Shoah une partie de
votre famille maternelle va être
déportée va revenir d'ailleurs pour un
blouson bon c'est cet événement tragique
mais on a l'impression malgré tout que
malgré cette épisode épouvantable
l'affection pour la france terre
d'accueil l'envie d'y demeurer et de s'y
épanouir et finalement de rompre avec
les racines initiales pour s'intégrer
dans le pays d'accueil ne va pas en être
affecté mon père parlait comme le père
de Mariam il trouvait que la France
c'est un pays formidable tout était
formidable les représentent combien il a
fait beaucoup la route le réseau routier
était formé tout était formidable et
effectivement bon
nous on a été quatre enfants on a été
élevé vers les trois aînés
dans une période où mes parents étaient
d'une énorme pauvreté mais on a tous été
à l'école on est tous rentrés au lycée
et on a tous fait des études qui nous
ont conduit bon là là où nous sommes et
tout ça n'a pas posé de de problèmes
donc mon père surtout mon père
d'ailleurs parce que mon père était
assez aimé bien dire ce qu'il aimait
il aimait la France et pour nous
ça ne pose aucun problème nous sommes
c'est notre pays c'est notre langue
c'est notre pays et d'ailleurs votre
livre tombeau et comme l'expression de
ça parce que vous êtes la dernière
génération votre grand-père était dans
le monde il dit je votre père était à
mi-chemin des deux univers et vous pour
vous ce monde là c'est un monde c'est un
passé qui ne passe pas bien sûr mais
c'est un monde d'hier c'est que vous
êtes dans le ils étaient vendredi soir
vivante de cette immigration et vous
êtes dans la mémoire et d'ailleurs vous
écrivez un tombeau parce que c'est une
nostalgie absolument j'ai eu ce
sentiment donc c'est aussi ça qui m'a
fait
accéléré mon écriture que
j'étais la dernière génération en
interface avec ce monde et
je mets une citation de Richard Ford en
exergue
qui dit en gros que nos parents des
panneaux grands-parents nous sont
étrangers c'est pas notre monde mais il
y a quelque chose qui nous lie à nous à
eux et et ce livre je verrai comme un
lien
avec
mes parents mes grands-parents avec ce
monde et je pense que c'est important
d'avoir ce lien c'est pas une question
de transmission je sais plus très bien
ce que ça veut dire la transmission mais
c'est une question de reconnaître que
quelque chose on sait pas quoi nous dire
à cet
universcat tombe c'est un livre très
sensible très touchant et très
intéressant qui qui est universel en
vérité par ce que sont son projet
dépasse de loin la question particulière
qu'elle évoque et beaucoup d'entre nous
pourraient se reconnaître dans cette
histoire a commencé d'ailleurs par
Marianne Tiga ni mine c'est le nom du
village de votre père que c'est
recruteurs au moment où ils l'ont attiré
en France lui ont donné et c'est eux qui
l'ont donné ce nom et je au fond votre
projet Mariam
[Musique]
le même que celui d'Annette me
semble-t-il votre point de départ c'est
que vous ne voulez pas que cette
histoire de milliers d'ouvriers anonymes
venus du Maroc et ayant immigré en
France où l'histoire de votre frère
ouvrier spécialisé chez Renault ne se
perdent pas ne disparaissent pas et vous
avez voulu garder la trace de ça non oui
bien sûr je suis honorée d'être face à
notre cas et évidemment en fait je pense
qu'il faut avoir aussi la décence de
comprendre que moi ma famille n'a pas
vécu en fait ni le génocide ni la
déportation
mais oui en fait j'ai voulu raconter
leur histoire mais finalement raconter
une plus grande histoire à la fois une
histoire populaire à la fois une
histoire ouvrière en fait française
parce qu'on est aussi dans une époque où
on a en fait des forces d'extrême droite
raciste qui avance un peu partout pas
qu'en France en Europe
à travers le monde et que cette question
de l'immigration elle est toujours
d'actualité et j'ai voulu en fait
documenter une partie de cette histoire
donc mon père a fait partie en fait d'un
des recrutements main d'oeuvre
étrangères les plus les plus importants
l'histoire contemporaine française
il a quel âge il a 15 ou 16 ans il a pas
l'âge exactement
on va le chercher dans un village du fin
fond de l'Atlas marocain on va le
chercher dans son village pauvre il est
recruté il est emmené en France dans des
conditions d'ailleurs très difficiles on
va y revenir et il est recruté par les
Charbonnages de France il va devenir
mineur dans les dans le nord de la
France au départ et tout se périple est
un périple qui en lui-même est très très
dur en très rude pour lui oui donc il
est recruté en 63 donc c'est la première
fois qu'il va sortir de son village qui
va découvrir en fait autre chose que son
village déjà au Maroc ensuite jusqu'à
Casablanca pour prendre le bateau
vers Marseille ensuite prendre le car
jusqu'à Lens et donc il va rester
pendant 8 ans mineure de fond toujours
dans le fond parce que lui c'est qu'on
part en fait ont été recrutés pour
fermer les mines donc il y avait une
grande politique en fait une grande fin
de l'air minière française les mines
n'étaient plus rentables au niveau de
leur exploitation et donc mon père va
faire partie de ces Marocains qu'on a
fait venir pour fermer les mines de
France et donc il y reste 8 ans travail
extrêmement dur dangereux dangereux donc
ils sont vraiment au poste les plus les
plus durs mon père était souvent à
l'abattage donc avec des grosses
machines pour donc taper dans le charbon
et essayer d'exploiter le maximum de
charbon possible et malgré ça en fait
mon père me dit que qu'il est heureux
d'avoir fait ça on va revenir à ça on va
revenir à ça alors d'abord il est mineur
pendant 7 ou 8 ans il y a d'ailleurs
80000 marocains qui ont été qu'on a
qu'on a été chercher pour les emmener
dans ces conditions là
et puis ensuite il quitte le nord de la
France et là il va devenir
os chez Renault il se marie sa femme
vient du même village que lui il se
marie il s'installe dans le célèbre site
du Val Fourré donc vous décrivez
d'ailleurs l'évolution au cours du temps
mais vous vous n'allez comprendre que
plus tard que vous êtes pauvre que vous
appartenez à la classe ouvrière enfin
vous n'êtes pas du tout dans les
conditions le le dans votre enfance
c'est pas comme ça que vous le vivez non
parce que déjà j'ai la chance d'être la
dernière donc évidemment j'ai eu quand
même une meilleure condition matériel
que mes frères et sœurs parce que je
ouais j'ai mon frère bon je parle aussi
dans le livre qui est qui a 15 ans de
plus que moi donc il a commencé à
travailler très jeune et donc j'ai j'ai
grandi voilà en voyant aussi mes sœurs
faire des études supérieures donc comme
comme je l'écris mon frère je ne savais
pas ce qui va après le brevet mais ça on
ne savait pas ce qui va après le bac et
moi en fait on a un peu expliqué tout ce
qu'il y avait mais bon racontez c'était
un peu comme un aide d'ailleurs la
volonté d'ascension sociale vous
raconter que même votre frère donc vous
faites un portrait très touchant votre
frère aîné celui qui est resté ouvrier
même lui sous l'effet probablement de la
culture familiale a échappé à la
délinquance d'un côté ou à la
radicalisation religieuse qui était les
devoirs de révolte de sa génération de
de des autres fils d'immigrés de de
votre de votre cité et après pour des
raisons multiples certaines qui nous
échappent parce que je vais un moment je
parle d'une famille voisine et qui on
partage les mêmes caractéristiques
socio-économiques avec des parents
aimants des frères et soeurs qui
s'entendaient bien et dont l'un des fils
a fini en fait djihadiste et donc je
j'essaie de comprendre est-ce que ma
famille était meilleure non en fait je
pense qu'il y a aussi un facteur chance
et donc mon frère lui bon a aussi a eu
la malchance d'être l'aîné d'être le
seul garçon donc avait il y avait la
double vigilance de mon père en fait sur
lui mon père a pas été toujours été très
sympa avec lui a été peut-être beaucoup
plus dur enfin clairement beaucoup plus
dur avec lui qu'avec nous ma mère aussi
à son âme était quelqu'un en fait qui
qui accordait beaucoup d'importance à
l'école peut-être plus que que mon père
et qui avait en fait une blessure une
blessure interne
voilà parce qu'elle a été longtemps
illettré
qu'elle a appris elle-même à lire très
tardivement je crois qu'on ne dira
jamais assez le rôle des mers dans la
trajectoire de de d'intégration et
d'ascension elle a appris à lire parce
qu'en fait elle voulait avoir accès aux
textes religieux et donc moi j'étais
toujours fascinée par ma mère qui était
une personne extrêmement pieuse qui
était très parcimonieuse dans sa manière
de parler mais même dans sa manière de
consommer les choses et qui en même
temps au fond de moi j'étais persuadée
que en fait qu'elle savait que tout ça
c'était n'importe quoi mais bon voilà et
je dis voilà que la religion était
libératrice pour elle elle a été un
moteur à un moment donné comme pour
l'humanité à un moment donné mais
qu'ensuite en fait elle a un peu enfermé
dans ce que j'ai trouvé très touchant
dans votre livre de tout le récit est
extrêmement intéressant mais ce que j'ai
trouvé très touchant c'est l'honnêteté
avec laquelle vous qui êtes très engagé
politiquement et qui est très
contestataire de cette société
capitaliste qui exploite les
travailleurs c'est la manière dont vous
racontez votre dialogue au père qui à
qui vous dites mais tu as été exploité
et votre père vous dit mais c'était pas
content d'être en France donc il avait
lui comme le de raconter Annette tout à
l'heure il avait quand même le goût il a
vous a transmis le goût du pays
d'accueil il avait le goût et puis je
pense aussi qu'il en fait il savait
pertinemment qu'il avait été exploité
qu'on était venu le chercher pour sa
force de travail et non pas par
humanisme
mais que en fait il a pu comparer sa
situation à celle de ses frères à celle
de ses cousins de ses neveux rester
derrière que lui en fait faisait vivre
tout un village et au fur et à mesure
moi j'ai aussi essayé de lui expliquer
que c'était une histoire
franco-marocaine parce que oui le Maroc
en fait donc cette histoire s'est passée
à la fin de la colonisation et au moment
de la décolonisation et en fait pense
pas que la France comme acteur de de
cette histoire et de cette opération il
y avait aussi la monarchie est-ce que
vous avez reconnu quelque chose de votre
histoire avec toutes les différences
dans le livre de Mariam ce qui me
fascine c'est que moi je pensais que
notre génération la mienne nous sommes
tous êtres suis-je le classe aujourd'hui
c'est donner un mot à la mode mais c'est
vraiment toute une génération et là je
vois qu'avec le décalage chronologique
c'est un peu un peu pareil
c'est à dire que
il y a cette
cette mobilité sociale cette mobilité
sociale qui passe quand même par l'école
par l'université et qui permet que des
filles davantage peut-être que des
filles d'ouvriers non qualifiées
deviennent
enfin change change le classe et je me
dis que dans cette période France
bashing permanent où on a l'impression
qu'on vit dans le pays le plus terrible
et où il y a le poids de tout le
colonialisme antimitisme et bien c'est
encore un pays qui reste
un peu ouvert et on n'est pas si
malheureux d'habiter et vous marier à
vous vous reconnaissez en lisant le
livre de de Danette vous allez reconnu
des traits de votre expérience de
d'arriver dans familiale oui évidemment
mais encore une fois avec vraiment la
défense aussi de
se dire ouais non mais de se dire
quand ils arrivent dans les années 20 et
jusqu'en 39 ils ont une vie d'immigrés
certes Juifs parce que c'est un racisme
et pas raciste pas comme les autres mais
il faut ne pas connaître la fin
il est pas inscrit quand ils arrivent de
Pologne nous allons poursuivre si vous
le voulez bien cette conversation avec
un lecteur Jérémy qui va poser une
question à Annette vieux qui a Jérémy on
vous écoute
[Musique]
je m'appelle Jérémy j'ai 24 ans j'ai
plus ou moins toujours aimé hier je
pense que c'est en partie lié au fait
que je voyais ma mère quand j'étais
petit et globalement c'est une passion
qui m'a suivi mais qui est vraiment
devenu important pour moi quand j'ai eu
à peu près 18 ans en sortant du lycée en
lisant Stephen Zweig lettre à un inconnu
et le joueur d'échec qui m'ont vraiment
donné envie de plus lire parce que je
voulais pas passer à côté de ce genre
d'histoire qui était vraiment prenantes
et donc j'ai continué de faire ça de
manière moi aussi plus intense
dernièrement j'ai lu l'être un jeune
poète de Maria reinerilk dans lequel on
a un officier qui va demander à Maria
Ryan Rilke son avis sur ses poésies et
très rapidement on a ce poète qui est
donc confirmé qui va lui dire que son
avis sur l'art n'a pas grand intérêt et
qui va donc enchaîner sur plutôt son
rapport à l'art son rapport à la vie son
rapport à la solitude et très rapidement
du coup on se retrouve avec la vie d'un
poète qui est en discussion avec un fan
mais une personne qui apprécie beaucoup
ses écrits et qui va pouvoir en
apprendre beaucoup plus sur la vie en
général que sur la poésie bonjour
Annette vidorca j'ai lu votre livre dans
lequel on se rend compte que c'est
important pour vous donc de transmettre
l'histoire on voit ça notamment avec le
fait que vous ayez écrit un livre qui
s'adresse en partie à votre film et
également au plus jeune sur l'histoire
de la Shoah et je me demandais en 2023
comment on continue à alimenter cette
histoire et comment on s'adressait aux
plus jeunes qui sont moins proches de
cette partie de l'histoire à travers
notamment leur famille qui sont pas vécu
ce genre de choses
Annette un vaste vaste question
je pense qu'on peut pas retenir le temps
qui passe qu'on va pas retenir les
générations et que aujourd'hui on est à
deux générations au sens biblique et
pratiquement 3 au sens démographique de
ces événements donc ces événements sont
entrés dans l'histoire et
la transmission elle passe
par l'enseignement de l'histoire
qui est plutôt pas mal fait sur cette
question et puis il passe aussi par la
littérature vous avez cité Stéphane soit
on aurait pu citer de Stéphane le monde
d'hier mais sur le sujet qui sur lequel
j'ai travaillé vous avez Charles Delbos
vous avez Prismo Lévy vous avez une
pierre pêche vous savez des films ça
veut dire que la mémoire vive
celle qui se transmet dans les
générations celles dont Mariam et moi
sommes redevables cette mémoire va
disparaître au profit d'une mémoire
culturelle comme la guerre et la paix
qui nous ont gardé la mémoire des
batailles napoléoniennes absolument
cette émission s'achève mais avant
qu'elle ne se termine tout à fait il
faut que on partage avec nos lecteurs
nos goûts littéraires nos goûts parce
qu'on peut pas inviter tous les autos à
tous les livres mais on peut en parler
et donc je vais vous demander à chacune
d'entre vous quel est le livre que vous
aimeriez faire donc vous aimeriez
partager le plaisir attention c'est
satisfait ou remboursé et il faut que le
lecteur qui vous écoute soit
enthousiaste après vous avoir lu Mariam
quel est le livre que vous voudriez que
nous lisions oui alors moi en fait en ce
moment je lis pas beaucoup enfin je lis
beaucoup de d'articles scientifiques et
de livres dans le cadre de ma thèse donc
voilà j'ai pas voulu mentir et donc j'ai
bien envie de vous conseiller un livre
qui s'appelle le fabuleux chantier
rendent l'intelligence artificielle
robustement bénéfique parce que je
travaille notamment en fait sur
l'intelligence artificielle et donc
c'est un livre qui a été écrit par deux
chercheurs lesbienne Hong elle m'a dit
elle m'a dit alors en 2000 il est sorti
en 2019 mais il est un peu passé
inaperçu malheureusement et pourtant en
fait il parlait déjà de cyberger de des
informations
des ravages de l'antivaxinisme de la
malformation des news etc et vraiment en
ces temps ouais trouble je pense que
c'est une bonne lecture qui est pointue
mais accessible et qui est une critique
raisonnée et raisonnable de ce que font
les intelligences artificielles à nos
démocraties
j'ai lu d'une traite un livre que j'ai
trouvé merveilleux avec une écriture
exceptionnelle qui le livre de Mathieu
Lindon qui s'appelle une archive alors
vous pensez bien que une historienne
comme moi avec un titre une archive
et c'est en
lui-même Mathieu Lindon comme archives
de ceux qui ont été les éditions de
Minuit je pense à plusieurs de
publications
et les visuels la nuit
l'affaire aux
daims et puis je n'ai pas oublié parce
que c'est
ça fait partie de mes lectures que ça a
été l'éditeur de de Charlotte Delbo
aussi et d'autres récits de déportés
donc il est la foi l'archive le témoin
d'une maison d'édition où la question du
témoin a été
importante alors à au bonheur des livres
on a choisi pour vous enfin pas vraiment
pour vous mais on vous recommande
Catherine Mansfield c'est l'édition en
poche Catherine mansfit cet auteur
anglaise néo-zélandaise en fait du début
du 20e siècle qui a une vie incroyable
de liberté sexuelle sentimentale
littéraire qui vit entre l'Angleterre
menton la France il y a des amours
complexes
homosexuels pour l'essentiel mais aussi
hétérosexuel et qui a beaucoup marqué
par son écriture très innovante
j'allais dire c'est pas Asnières nous
mais
enfin bref il y a marqué la littérature
anglaise et qu'on connaît finalement
assez mal en France je suis sûr que ça
va vous intéresser
je suis Elsa Triolet c'est la biographie
une biographie à la première personne
d'Elsa Triolet Elsa Triolet donc qui est
sous-estimé parce qu'elle l'ombre portée
de d'Aragon pèse sur elle alors que
c'est un personnage finalement
probablement très dur mais très
intéressant je suis sûr que ça va vous
intéresser vous
[Musique]
Javier mariage Thomas nevinson revient
maria sa grand auteur espagnol qui vient
de mourir à ces son dernier livre
posthume personnage là encore ou en
couleur
académicien mais anti-conformiste
refusant tous les honneurs et considéré
comme un très très grand auteur espagnol
et puis enfin une bande dessinée car on
s'emploie à promouvoir aussi la bande
dessinée Adèle Blanc-Sec Tardy Tardy est
un immense auteur de bandes dessinées à
delblanca qui est une série très très
connue le bébé des Buttes-Chaumont qui
est la dernière le dernier épisode en
date en date d'Adèle Blanc-Sec voilà
cette émission s'achève merci de nous
avoir suivi merci à Annette vive Urka et
à Mariam qui ganini de pour le récit
sensible et vraiment touchant de
l'immigration de leurs parents à deux
périodes
successives pardon et dans deux univers
culturels distincts mais enfin avec
beaucoup de miroitent entre les deux qui
nous permet de mieux comprendre ce
qu'est l'immigration mais ce qu'est la
France aussi vu à travers les immigrés
merci à notre lecteur Jérémy vous pouvez
revoir cette émission sur le site de
Public Sénat ou sur vos plateformes
préférées et nous nous revoyons la
semaine prochaine sauf si nous nous
croisons dans une librairie d'ici là
bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]